the rule is simple you dad
let's go browse Batman but I removed
some animations oh my god I love these
okay pretty normal so far
[Music]
alright let's see let's see the bad man
come on he's gonna show but no goddamn
place type you'll be out of here before
anyone could stop us
but what I thought that's all they
needed to do to fix the telltale games
this is remove all the animations and
it's too many times batteries
sometimes you need
[Music]
get on my back
while the action is incredible
when they learn what is his new
jiu-jitsu
without a scratch so far you broke the
law
why is it so funny so dumb
alright I think that's enough ten out of
ten well I guess I fail already first
clip guess I'll die I'm fine
turns out I have an extra life there's
bridges important but there are two
bridges looked at I'll make sure to
steer us away from those okay I played
for at night for three hours and it was
totally fine I'm so proud of myself who
says I haven't become a better person
who says I can't learn from my mistakes
Thank You Nina yeah very cool you know
you know lots of things but play games
are you satisfied are there things that
frustrate you about games what do you
want to see games do I don't say I don't
know I mean like I mean I've bit more
r-rated part is like we're on it we're
working on it dope that's awesome yeah
this clip aged well a preview of when
doc goes back to games
[Music]
oh I get it
he entered the bathroom I get it he got
banned again talk solely weakness I got
my Bridget dogs got his bathrooms see
the full context here is that he went
into a bathroom he filmed inside a
public bathroom I used to be such a big
doctor disrespect fan how could doctor
disrespect do this doesn't he know that
there's penises flying everywhere in a
bathroom has anyone ever been in a
goddamn bathroom like a men's bathroom I
know half of you having it's not like
that
maybe I don't get it I clearly don't get
it well you won't see penis unless you
go mm-hmm
like just filming in the bathroom but
clearly people know there's a camera I
don't really see a problem in that all
right if you go in their bathroom with a
hidden camera
now that's freaked up okay it could have
been so bad hey there I'm James McAvoy
and you're only one week away from
seeing Sherlock Holmes and theaters and
get your tickets in the know I can't
wait to see Sherlock gnomes he looks
completely faded and where it is held
hostage James McAvoy and you're only one
week away he's good know me oh they're
torturing from seeing Sherlock Holmes
and theatres you know get your tickets
in the link below James McAvoy what else
has he acted in what the same guy he's
been in so many good Phelps late wasn't
that great why is he not credited there
it is Sherlock Holmes
Gnomeo and Juliet hey this man signed a
contract seven years ago
see this is thing they did with actors
right if they want to do a sequel I
think they're contracted to it most
likely he was only one week away from
seeing Sherlock Holmes and God sorry I
feel for him I really truly do
oh I see you're trained in the way of
the source but see the sore isn't
actually my weapon of choice
[Music]
goddammit is that blatant sorcery yeah
it is what did they do to the game Perry
this you casual we're done you missed
you had one chance to kill me come on
yeah you could fake that pretty silly
couldn't you especially if you're
standing on this side right fake woman
who got an eyeball tattoo may lose her
eye
now she's warning others no need to warn
me I'm not guys don't get an eyeball
tattoo it's really bad what sorry it's
not funny I feel free clearly a lot of
people do get those tattoos she's done
every right move in telling other people
of the risks of course of course of
course
1998 Yahoo refuses to buy Google for 1
million dollars
geez is that true that can't be true
2002 four years later yahoo realizes its
mistake and tries to buy google for
three billion google says give us five
yeah who says no six years later yeah
who refuses to be sold to Microsoft for
forty billion dollars okay alright eight
years later yahoo sold for 4.6 billion
now that's business yeah you did it yeah
damn isn't there a thing we're like in
Japan they don't use Google for some
reason they just people actually use
Yahoo there it's like the last bastion
meanwhile bing crying in the corner can
you imagine working for Bing just having
an uphill every single day e-e-e-e e-e-e
e-e-e-e
ee-ee-ee-ee I'm so glad at in life
that would have been embarrassing skewer
that they're trying to give her an
airlift then this is not this is not
funny
don't lose this Christ Akane look at
what's happening to the lady right you
think she's gonna slow down you think
you know hey let's put her down now I'm
sorry wait this is this is not working
the way we intended oh my god she can
human fidget spinner are you kidding me
this is what we've paid for I was
laughing at the commentary and not the
woman in pain did she get hurt my
number-one concern I think I already
heard that she was fine so I'm just
gonna go with that she's fine she's fine
she's fine
advice to victims of cyberbullying I
feel like I've seen this but I can't
remember
let's hear it
she drops the tile a pause right there
[Laughter]
[Music]
can we watch it without the cringy edits
did you hear that love your mother
but you see my mama did just love your
mother everyone people being mean to you
all your not loving your mother enough
PewDiePie brought me here
well clearly then I've already seen it
Jesus Christ and the memory of a
goldfish people like to make memes I
love that clip so what where is that
from Drake why's Drake encouraging memes
people like to make memes make a meme at
it is oh my god Drake confirmed for meme
review Drake I know you're watching ok
and all you do is all David's play for
at night and watch me review join this
people like memes I make a meme out of
it
wait I want to watch there it is my
favorite clip hey are you doing it Mick
Tommy here
hey doughnuts - gram it's big time Tommy
here's my thought of the day it might
lead over the best life you can haters
will hate always that's what they do
they hate hate but you know what they
hate themselves and live your life all
the ATIS that's the old school hey how
you doing it big shot that a bird ate it
they're really they ate them damn that's
the replies you should have given what's
your advice for cyber bullying it is
worry but really they hate them there oh
yes I've seen this beautiful foot well
did he know he got jebaited what does
jebaited mean jo baited that's what I
meant back in my day okay I can't keep
up with all these young kids cup pop
culture [ __ ] all right here we go
baby let's go world record run wow
that's some more minecraft guys okay
that's pretty epic
well well well there you have it
and then on the high note well it looks
like I laughed so I guess I'll die thank
you guys for watching subscribe smash
like check out the merch strick emerge
very epic in as always - see you
tomorrow broski's I said 100 million
then it's the brofist but y'all just
won't subscribe to some reason like I
don't understand it's almost like you
just wanted me to be
[Music]
what you never played super simulator
you know it's fun right I'm not supposed
to give my opinion but give it a try and
then you can tell me if it's good or not
not convinced yet okay I'll cut you a
deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Music]